es ist eine schwedische
bilderbuchlandschaft hier draußen
erwärmen eine gute halbe stunde
außerhalb von stockholm doch diese tage
rund um ostern sind eine traurige zeit
für thomas caroline und näher
vor einem jahr ist die jungen gestorben
thomas bruder karolines vater irgendwo
auf dem weg zur arbeit dann einkaufen
oder im büro hatte er sich mit corona
infiziert danach klingt alles ganz
schnell
ich hatte noch einmal mit papa
telefoniert kurz bevor sie ihn ins
künstliche koma versetzt haben
er sagte noch sei nicht traurig das ist
alles nicht so schlimm
keine angst zu haben ich weiß nicht ob
er mich nur beruhigen wollte aber es hat
mir geholfen wenn er denkt es ist nicht
ernst so dachte ich dann ist es auch
nicht ernst aus dem cobra ist tirol aber
nicht wieder erwacht er ist einer von
schwedens über 13.000 toten im
zusammenhang mit korea so viele gibt es
in keinem anderen land skandinaviens
längst hat die regierung ihren
international beachteten kurs milder
carola ratschläge verlassen auch in
schweden gibt es keine treffen mehr mit
über acht personen wo immer möglich wird
im home-office gearbeitet theater
universitäten kino und museen sind
geschlossen
aber zu masken wird nur geraten und
restaurants dürfen mit einschränkungen
noch bis 20 uhr 30 gäste bewirten
normalerweise sitzen die gäste eng
zusammen jetzt müssen sie mindestens
einen meter abstand einhalten und dürfen
maximal zu viert am tisch sitzen
deswegen haben wir viel weniger gäste
unser umsatz liegt bei 35 prozent pro
jahr
schweden steht in diesen tagen am
scheideweg noch mehr beschränkungen oder
weiter durch die pandemie
hindurchschlängeln starts epidemiologe
tech nel hat in einer internationalen
pressekonferenz weitere lockerungen erst
einmal ausgeschlossen
wir überlegen auch in einem weiteren
schritt unterschiedliche einrichtungen
wie zb fitnessstudios zu schließen wenn
die infektionsraten an solchen orten
steigen
zu hause in den schären redet die
18-jährigen er mit ihren angehörigen
viel über den tod des onkels aber sie
erlebt gleichzeitig wie die maßnahmen
gegen korona ihr leben weiter
einschränken
oben kann sie nur noch zu hause mit
ihrem vater ihr musikstudium aber nicht
auf eis die studierenden dürfen nicht
mehr zusammenspielen
ich hatte mich natürlich darauf gefreut
ganz viel live musik zu machen ich
wollte es aus kosten auf so eine schule
zu gehen wo alle für die gleichen sachen
brennen für musik und für musiker jetzt
können wir gar nicht miteinander spielen
alle konzerte wurden eingestellt das ist
schon traurig das gefühl dass nicht nur
das virus bedrohlich ist sondern dass
auch die maßnahmen zum schutz vor corona
schweren schaden anrichten schreibt
phillips hughes drüber seit der
stockholms erste größere demonstration
gegen die einschränkungen des alltags
organisiert hat ist der student ein
gefragter interviewpartner
man muss bei allen maßnahmen die vor und
nachteile abwägen
ich finde die gesundheitsbehörde und die
regierung machen politik ohne die gefahr
ihrer strategien zu beachten
diese diskussion wurde nicht geführt vor
allem in einer zeit wo es uns schlecht
geht müssen wir zusammenrücken
aber wir werden isoliert das macht krank
und ist ungefähr in schweden wächst der
protest gegen die korona maßnahmen immer
öfter gehen menschen auf die straße muss
die polizei eingreifen
und immer wieder warnen auch experten
von den folgen des schwedischen
beschränkungen
man sollte die risikogruppen besser
schützen also die älteren und alle mit
voller kraft
gleichzeitig aber müssen wir
einschränkungen die distanz unterricht
abschaffen denn sowas belastet die
kinder und ihre familien vor allem wenn
sie beengt wohnen auf schulessen
angewiesen sind oder kein internet haben
sowas gibts ja nicht nur in deutschland
wenig jüngeren also alle freiheiten
zurückgeben während kranke und alte sich
isolieren
über diese frage streiten die schweben
viele senioren sehen sich an den rand
der gesellschaft gedrängt sollen die
verantwortung für ihre sicherheit
übernehmen von uns älteren hatten aber
viele das gefühl wir sollten uns
zurückziehen uns unsichtbar machen
wir wurden von jungen leuten im
supermarkt befragt was wir eigentlich
machen wir sollten sie nicht anstecken
dabei ging es doch eigentlich um unseren
schutzweste holmen ist schwedens älteste
parlamentarierin wie viele ihres alters
hatte sie sich lange zurückgezogen hielt
abstand zu den jungen ihre politischen
aufgaben halfen hier durch die zeit der
isolation
sie kennt aber viele die solch einen
rückzug in die einsamkeit nicht
ausgehalten haben
ich wurde von einer person kontaktiert
die gerade ihren hundertsten geburtstag
gefeiert hatte und mich fragte wie sie
sich das leben nehmen können
von einer anderen person weiß ich dass
sie sich umgebracht hat weil sie die
isolation nicht ausgehalten hat ist ja
to live dorf sich caroline thomas und
näher denken haben jahrestag seines
todes viel an jungen und suchen
gemeinsam trost während sie erleben dass
irland in der dritten welle der pandemie
vor einer zerreißprobe steht